[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au mercredi 7
semaines l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités et nos reporters sur le
terrain tout de suite les grands titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 30
décembre
la campagne de vaccination se poursuit
en france lentement mais sûrement une
cadence jugée trop lente par rapport à
d'autres pays comme le royaume uni qui
approuve le vaccin astrazeneca moins
coûteux et plus facile à distribuer que
celui de father biotech accélérant ainsi
la cadence en europe ce vaccin ne sera
pas autorisée avant février
[Musique]
l'accord post briques site les chefs
d'état européens l'ont paraphé ce matin
avant son approbation dans l'après midi
par le parlement britannique suivie
d'une signature de boris johnson son
application provisoire est prévu le 1er
janvier dans la tempe d'une ratification
définitive par les eurodéputés le
royaume uni sera un voisin amical de
l'union européenne les mots du premier
ministre britannique aujourd'hui
et puis ces cris de joie en argentine un
jour historique là bas et dans toute
l'amérique latine après que le congrès a
légalisé l'avortement
après les députés mi-décembre les
sénateurs plutôt conservateurs ont
adopté le texte
il avait plusieurs fois rejetées des
moutures similaires dans le passé
libéré il sera possible jusqu'à 14
semaines de grossesse était une promesse
du président de centre gauche alberto
finlandaise au pouvoir depuis la fin
le royaume-uni donne son feu vert au
vaccin oxford astrazeneca fait
clairement d'un coup d'accélérateur à sa
campagne de vaccination déjà bien
entamée l'agencé britannique du
médicament l'a autorisé tôt ce matin ses
avantages moins coûteux plus facile à
stocker et plus simple à distribuer que
le vaccin father biotech en europe sans
autorisation n'est pas attendues avant
février
l'argentine elle vient de l'autoriser
les etats-unis eux milles sur une
acceptation vers avril et pour homme
attend coop
le ministre de la santé britannique
c'est un moment extrêmement important
dans la lutte contre la pandémie et
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour tout le
monde un message envoyé sur twitter hier
soir son homologue français olivier
ferrand a défendu la lenteur du
démarrage de la campagne de vaccination
c'est vrai qu'en france nous n'avançons
pas au même rythme il s'agit selon lui
de prendre le temps de la pédagogie et
d'éviter des erreurs
par ailleurs il a rappelé l' alerte du
conseil scientifique qui juge probable
une reprise incontrôlée de l'épidémie en
en janvier en raison du rebond à des
contaminations et du risque de
propagation plus grands à la veille du
nouvel an et ailleurs dans le monde
eh bien on avance avec d'autres vaccins
le venezuela par exemple attend la
livraison de 10 millions de doses du
spoutnik v élaboré en russie les
autorités ont signé un contrat avec
moscou elle souhaite lancer la campagne
de vaccination le plus tôt possible et
d'autres pays ont fait un choix
identique l'argentine ou encore la
biélorussie se tourner vers spoutnik
vais le vaccin russe ya été livrées ces
derniers jours pour permettre le
démarrage des campagnes de vaccination
le récit c'est avec médiers ce qu'est
fils l'argentine premier état
latino-américain à déployer spoutnik
vais sur son territoire
buenos aires s accorde sa confiance au
vaccin russe alors qu'en termes
d'infection il est le pays le plus
touché du continent après le brésil et
la colombie
une campagne de vaccination dans
laquelle le personnel de santé et
prioritaires au sein d'une population de
45 millions d'habitants les autorités
ont enregistré plus d'un million et demi
de cas positifs depuis le début de la
pandémie
après le mexique le costa rica le chili
l'argentine est désormais le quatrième
état d'amérique latine a lancé sa
campagne de vaccination contre le
coronavirus les argentins attendent
beaucoup de ce vaccin
kent au travail c'est grâce à notre
nation notre pays d'être capable de voir
ce jour est le début de la phase de
vaccination
on peut vraiment en être fier tous les
argentins peuvent être fiers et
continuer à travailler ensemble pour
protéger la population avec ce vaccin
[Applaudissements]
cela nous rassure un peu de penser que
c'est le début de la fin de cette
situation vraiment étrange et nous
attendions cela depuis tellement
longtemps de juste essayé de franchir
une première étape pour en finir avec ce
virus
je suis vraiment très fier
de leur côté les premiers below russes
ont reçu une injection de spoutnik v
après des essais cliniques menés par les
autorités locales après l'argentine la
biélorussie devient ainsi le deuxième
pays est homologué le vaccin russe le
ministre de la santé biélorusse a
indiqué que minsk était sur le point de
lancer sa propre production du remède
par des sociétés pharmaceutiques locales
il est très important de souligner que
nous avons reçu un vaccin prêt à être
utilisé qui a subi des tests cliniques
et qui a été homologué comme les airs il
est tout aussi important que dans la
coopération avec nos partenaires russes
nous travaillons actuellement dans le
cadre de la dernière phase de production
locale du vaccin spoutnik v par nos
sociétés pharmaceutiques du non-match
masters la russie a signé des accords
avec plusieurs pays d'amérique latine et
d'asie pour livrer des doses du vaccin
ces derniers jours des lots de spoutnik
veillant notamment été réceptionnés en
hongrie et nous retrouvons un philippe
froguel chercheur généticien professeur
à l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université lille ii bonsoir à vous
chez les pros galles merci
d'être en direct avec nous ce soir sur
rtl france en a bien sûr parlé de ce
vaccin astrazeneca tout juste approuvé
par le régulateur britannique mais
d'abord un point quand même sur la
manière dont se déroule au royaume y la
campagne de vaccination se déroule très
bien apparemment puisque il ya plusieurs
centaines de milliers de d'anglais qui
ont été vaccinées en part notamment des
gens très âgés de l'équivalence qu'on
appelle des ehpad anglais et puis du
personnel de santé et ça va ça va
continuer et avec l'arrivée de celui
d'astrazeneca
il ya un véritable changement puisque
aujourd'hui et les autorités
britanniques ont annoncé leur volonté en
gros de vacciner tout le monde
c'est ce qui va vraiment modifier les
choses
il ya des raisons à cette explosion du
nombre de nouveaux cas les hôpitaux qui
sont en partie submergée mais là on est
dans une situation qui ressemble à ce
qui se passe en israël qui est du pays
mais c'est comme très intéressant de
voir quel pays de 60 millions
d'habitants va être capable probablement
de vacciner toute la population à
vacciner tout le monde ça pourrait
vouloir dire peut-être un vaccination
rendu obligatoire ou pas du tout ça je
ne peux pas vous dire je connais pas la
situation en angleterre là dessus je
pense que les anglais sont des gens
pragmatiques il se pose pas des
questions invraisemblables comme en
france avec des situations compliquées
on demande d autorisation avec une près
une pré discussions avec un médecin puis
ensuite une après en face et ses rangs
des choses très compliquées en france en
angleterre gens pragmatiques décision
efficace et ça marche
et alors astrazeneca semble présenter
certains avantages par rapport au vaccin
pfizer biotech
c'est la réalité peut-être qu'il est
mieux meilleurs qu'aux vaccin ou pas il
a comme avantage d'être moins cher et de
ne pas nécessiter d'être conservée à
moins 70 ce qui est un
avantage pour les allées britannique
elle a aussi l'intérêt d'être fait par
une boîte pharmaceutique anglaise un
astrazeneca
donc on est dans la situation absolument
idéal pour la pour la grande bretagne
qui a mis en place des centres de
vaccination extrêmement efficace à la
peur de ce qui se passe en france
alors vous dites que la campagne de
vaccination devrait s'accélérer au
royaume uni ce vaccin va vraiment
changer la donne il a été calculé par
les épidémiologistes anglais que si 40%
la population étaient vaccinés ont
diminué de 90 % la mortalité et ça c'est
quelque chose de très important et
progressivement on arrivera à l'immunité
collective donc à l'éradication de cette
maladie
ce vaccin comme les autres files
orienthèque il est efficace sur le virus
mutant
pour l'instant il ya aucune raison de
penser qu'il ne l'est pas c'est ce que
ce qui est sorti actuellement cela dit
pour le savoir il va falloir qu'on
administre ce vaccin et qu'on regarde ce
qui se passe pour les personnes qui ont
été vaccinées donc ça va prendre un
petit peu de un petit peu de temps mais
je pense qu'on a aucune raison à ce jour
de se poser cette question la question
et aux ricains et la transmission du
virus à priori par mois densité est rude
pour la transmission des virus je pense
que les médias se trompent là dessus
c'est pas qu'il ya pas d'efficacité
c'est que ça pas été testé la seule
chose qu'on a essayé de faire
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si des gens
qui étaient vaccinés devenait malade et
on n'a pas essayé de savoir si
transmettait à d'autres et et c'est
parce qu'il veut pas dire que ils vont
être contagieux moi je pense en fait
qu'ils sont pas contagieux comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui pour tous les vaccins
simplement ça n'a pas été testée
puisqu'on a fait très vite il aurait
fallu attendre un an ou deux pour le
savoir on présente en tout cas sur le
vieux continent le vaccin fiber bien de
tak comme la panacée
à tort ou à raison son le finder est le
premier à être arrivé c'est celui qui a
annoncé les meilleurs résultats avec
celui de modern à illettrés les
problèmes en très très bien il est aussi
le plus cher
il ya le gros avantage d'être être déjà
là et l'information du jour en français
c'est qu'on n'aura pas celui
d'astrazeneca avant longtemps et donc on
est dans une situation extrêmement
délicate dans notre pays avec un vaccin
de pfizer dans les frigos les
congélateurs
mais quand on n'arrive pas à distribuer
on a fait quand même moins d'une
centaine de vaccination à ce jour ce qui
est vraiment rien et d'autre part on a
prévu le gouvernement français a prévu
de vacciner 20 millions de personnes
seulement pourrais-je dire donc 10 à 15
par astrazeneca et 5 à 10 par par pfizer
ce qui veut dire aujourd'hui que puisque
le vaccin astrazeneca ne va pas arriver
tout de suite en europe et il faut se
poser la question pourquoi il n'y va pas
arriver tout de suite c'est simplement
parce qu astrazeneca n'a pas déposé de
dossier d'homologation jusqu'à présent
il ne compte pas le faire tout de suite
et pourquoi il compte pas le faire c'est
parce que en fait le gouvernement
britannique a demandé astrazeneca de
garder pour l'instant toutes ces doses
disponibles pour les britanniques
vous vous croyez les autorités
françaises quand lorsqu'elles disent
qu'elles vont rattraper leur retard sur
les autres pays au courant janvier dans
le cadre de la campagne de vaccination
oui et puis on va raser gratis demain
matin cc c'est bien connu il va y avoir
du soleil en janvier etc
non la situation à ce jour on rattrape
jamais un retard premièrement et si on
le rattrape c'est parce qu'on a un plant
changer tant qu'on n'aura pas modifié le
plan de vaccination français démontrer
aux français on a véritablement les
moyens logistiques de le faire ça va
s'améliorer très très doucement c'est à
dire qu'on rattrape
jamais ce retard dernière question s'il
y progresse qu'il faut se faire vacciner
moi je vais me faire vacciner le plus
vite possible probablement en grande
bretagne puisque en tant que sales
imperial college avoir le droit de faire
ça et moi je je je pense que toutes les
personnes de plus de 50 ans ont un grand
intérêt à se faire vacciner parce que le
risque est important pour eux mais en
réalité une grande partie de la
population a intérêt à le faire surtout
si on a une obésité un diabète ou autre
autre problème
je rappelle quand même que même les
jeunes de 20 ans 30 ans peuvent faire un
une maladie sévère et être embêté
pendant des mois avec des grandes sait
quelle est donc cette maladie est
bénigne pour personne parfois les armes
automatiques c'est très bien mais pour
les autres elle peut être vraiment
sévère et durer très très longtemps
merci beaucoup philippe froguel
chercheur généticien professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université lille 2 parallèlement à la
campagne de vaccination les mesures de
restriction se durcissent face aux
robots épidémique un couvre-feu avancé à
18h pour est entrée en vigueur dès
samedi dans certaines régions à hauts
risques
le grand test la bourgogne franche comté
l'auvergne rhône-alpes et le département
des alpes maritimes pas de confinement
locaux c'était une demande pressante
pourtant de certains élus qui
maintiennent la pression sur le
gouvernement
à nice par exemple on annonce une
campagne de vaccination anticipée ont
fait le point avec florian lambert pas
de confinement mais un début de
couvre-feu avancé à 18 heures qui ne
fait visiblement pas l'unanimité chez
les mères des régions concernées depuis
l'annnonce du ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand certains édiles font
entendre leur colère comme ici à nancy
avec le maire de la ville mathieu klein
je n'espère qu'une chose c'est me
tromper j'espère
que ce couvre feu sera suffisant
efficace j'ai simplement aujourd'hui à
l'épreuve de mes échanges quotidiens
avec les médecins avec l'hôpital le
sentiment que c'est sans doute
insuffisants et trop tardif déçus par
les mesures annoncées
certains maires n'hésite pas à prendre
eux mêmes les choses en main pour lutter
contre la pandémie covit 19 à nice par
exemple mr l'est républicain christian
estrosi a annoncé le lancement d'une
campagne de vaccination anticipée dès ce
mercredi
chaque territoire ayant sa spécificité
il se trouve que nous nous sommes
frontalier avec monaco avec l'italie
avec un aéroport qui est passé de 20
vols par jour à 120 vols
c'est à dire le niveau de 50 % de
fréquentation de décembre 2019
tout cela a ramené une circulation
importante du virus
tout comme nice la région du grand test
a également accéléré sa campagne de
vaccination elle débutera dès lundi 4
janvier
par ailleurs pour encourager leurs
concitoyens à faire de même
200 maires s'engagent à se faire
vacciner à l'origine de l'initiative
le maire de poissy karl olive qui
souhaitent lutter contre la défiance de
nombreux français face au vaccin
un travail pédagogique indispensable
puisque 40% des français sont encore
réticents à se faire immuniser et dans
le même temps seulement 40% d'entre eux
se disent prêts à se faire vacciner
selon les derniers chiffres de santé
publique france est la colère et la
frustration des mers justement c'est
l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
on en débat tout de suite avec nos
invités eric dérivés mère génération
terrain de la roche la molière dans la
loire et jacques myard mère l air de
maisons laffitte dans les yvelines
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france d'abord dans quel
état d'esprit vous êtes après les
annonces d'olive et veyran hier soir
eric dérivés je me tourne vers vous
d'abord dans quel état d'esprit toute
façon on est un petit peu rodé
maintenant depuis quelques mois à des
décisions qui change très rapidement et
donc comme tout bon maire que l'on mais
il faut qu'on s'adapte très rapidement
de façon efficace pour qu'on puisse
trouver des solutions sur le terrain
donc on est sur le terrain et on
s'adapte voilà c'est ça notre état
d'esprit
jacques nerfs vous êtes dans le même
état d'esprit écoutez il est évident
qu'on subit les choses aujourd'hui et
que on ne voit pas très bien ce qu'on
doit faire en priorité il il est clair
que aujourd'hui le gouvernement
démarrent les vaccinations avec un
retard qui est stupéfiant stupéfiants et
donc à ce titre on ne comprend pas
pourquoi alors que 500 milles vaccins
sont arrivés en france qu on a vacciné
jusqu'à présent que quelques dizaines de
personnes de plus parler d'un couvre-feu
parler d'un confinement
alors qu'on sait très bien que c'est
reculer pour mieux sauter c'est pas ça
qui va résoudre la chose la seule
possibilité c'est effectivement que il
faut absolument commencer en masse les
vaccins et je suis stupéfait de
constater que véritablement ça patine
pour parler haut et libère les vais vous
êtes d'accord avec un jacques néant tout
ce que vous vous êtes un signataire
d'ailleurs d'un manifeste de karl olive
qui est le cofondateur de votre
mouvement le maire de poissy qui appelle
les maires à se faire vacciner en
appelant justement à à l'exemplarité des
mères oui il ya deux problèmes il ya le
problème de la fourniture et de la
distribution et de des vaccins dans
notre pays et le problème de des
français qui sont un peu réticents à la
vaccination
et c'est pour ça qu'on propose avec
génération terrain et d'entre eux mais à
tous les maires qui sont volontaires de
montrer l'exemple parce que on est quand
même crédible nous
on est assez écoutée de nos concitoyens
on est apportée d'engueulades et
apporter aussi de service donc forcément
les gens nous connaissent et donc
peut-être de montrer l'exemple en se
faisant vacciner devant eux leur disant
voilà on y va suivez-nous pour que un
maximum de gens se fassent vacciner
on ne fait pas forcément pour nous on
fait pour les autres surtout un c'est un
signe d'intelligence et de deux
démarches collectives donc je pense que
c'est important mais c'est vrai que
comme le dit mon collègue de maisons
laffitte
il ya un souci peut-être de distribution
organisation en france parce qu'on a une
lourdeur administrative qui est
tellement lourde que la réactivité n'est
pas forcément toujours au rendez vous
jacques nerveux je crois que vous n'avez
pas signé justement ce manifeste si vous
l'avez fait d'accord donc vous y adhérez
vous vous y adhérez à 100%
il ya un devoir d'exemplarité de la part
des élus c'est un problème d'exemplarité
et c'est aussi pour dire à nos
concitoyens qui sont sceptiques
attention ne jouait pas trop avec le feu
on voit très bien que la la vaccination
a permis par exemple d'éradiquer la
poliomyélite la variole et donc
aujourd'hui ce vaccin il ya eu une
mauvaise communication au début parce
que la technique de la rn a été présenté
comme quelque chose qui n'avait pas été
utilisé dans le passé et à l'excellent
cannes nous a dit non pas du tout c'est
une méthode qu'on utilise pour combattre
le cancer depuis des années et des
années
donc on n'est pas dans je dirais une
terra incognita
on est dans une méthode qui a qui
commence à faire ses preuves
donc il faut dire à nos concitoyens et
les maires bien évidemment son parti de
ce combat regarder les choses en face
c'est la seule solution le vaccin pour
qu'on s'en sorte
donc n'ayez pas peur et au revoir
jusqu'à présent
jusqu'à présent je touche du bois en
tapant sur la tête
il est évident que il n'y a pas eu je
dirais donc
de contre-indication durable il ya eu
quelques personnes qui avaient la tête
un peu paralysés mais ça ne durait pas
donc je crois que c'est la seule
solution et il faut dédramatiser ce
vaccin j'ajoute une chose c'est que nous
les maires comme mon collègue ici
présent nous sommes capables non pas de
vacciner mais de mettre à disposition
des endroits des gymnases des salles
pour pouvoir recevoir nos concitoyens
par exemple en matière de tests à
maisons laffitte pendant une semaine on
a testé plus de 700 personnes
donc on voit bien qu'on est capable
d'apporter les moyens matériels
logistiques pour faire face alors vous
faisiez allusion à l'ex et lichens un
généticien qui lui a dit regretter
justement le la lenteur dans la
stratégie de cette campagne de
vaccination on va y revenir mais puisque
vous faites référence au devoir
d'exemplarité des élus vous regrettez
que les membres du gouvernement et que
des membres aussi des autorités de santé
ne soit pas sur la même longueur d'onde
que joue pour toi il ne se ferait pas
vacciner devant les caméras par exemple
ça pourrait inciter effectivement les
français à se faire vacciner massivement
qu'en pensez vous juste un point on va
pas faire du voyeurisme banques la reine
d'angleterre se vaccine etc
moi je veux bien que le président de la
république aussi mais là c'est une
question on n'est pas là pour faire de
la communication s'était passé
jacqueline r c'était le cas le week-end
dernier vous avez peut-être vu du ch
il y avait aussi un cardiologue qui
s'est fait vacciner devant les caméras
et mais ce qui est beaucoup plus grave
chez que visuellement n'y a pas un plan
d'urgence pour vacciner le personnel de
santé
ça c'est un problème est là je crois que
il faut que le gouvernement met le
paquet et je ne comprends pas cette
lenteur eric est un berlivet oui alors
en fait on a un souci d'intelligence
collective et de coordination
en fait les welsches sont un peu grippée
peut-être au niveau national on a on a
des possibilités dans nos communes sur
ma commune j'ai une entreprise qui
fabrique des containers isotherme pour
transporter les vaccins et qui va
distribuer dans l'ensemble de la france
justement ces vaccins il faut qu'on ait
une harmonie que la rs dans chaque
région au corps en donne on a les moyens
sur les communes dans l'est
appartements dans les régions de
coordonner tout ça le problème c'est
qu'on sait pas qui fait quoi et des fois
on voit que sur le terrain nous on est
là pour pallier aux manques ou
questionnement qu'on peut se poser on
est là et comme comme dans d'autres
communes on est tous aussi est
disponible pour préparer pour accueillir
et organiser les choses en attaque
personnelle
les gens les bénévoles on a tout ce
qu'il faut pour coordonner les choses
mais il faut qu'on donne le tempo et qui
a un rythme soutenu est ce que vous
pourriez suivre par exemple l'initiative
de du mr estrosi qui lui annoncé une
campagne anticipée
une campagne de vaccination anticipée je
suis fou pardon je suis fort heureux
d'apprendre qu'il a récupéré des vaccins
parce que pense pour l'instant en ce qui
concerne la ville de maisons-laffitte
même si je ne suis pas maison la petite
aujourd'hui il n'en demeure pas moins
que je n'ai eu aucune connaissance que
la rs nous a dit attention on arrive
avec 1000 2000 vaccin ou qu'on va
vacciner en priorité dans les ehpad
pour l'instant on est comme l'oiseau sur
la blanc la branche
on attend et c'est à la rs véritablement
de nous informer le plus rapidement
possible et libère lives et on est ce
qu'à votre avis on est confronté à un
problème de stop parlons franchement
en fait on n'a pas d'information si on
avait de la formation seraient les
premiers à acheter des vaccins comme on
était les premiers à acheter des masques
commandés été les premiers à acheter des
tests et mais il faut qu'on ait ces
vaccins pour qu'on puisse être distribué
dans une bonne condition mais
aujourd'hui on n'a pas d'informations en
tout cas les autorités annoncent un
million de doses disponibles dans le
courant du mois de janvier
le manque 500 millions certes mais je
crois que à ce moment là il va falloir
organiser la priorité des priorités
moi je pense que les personnes âgées
serre mais aussi les personnels
soignants et donc ça va poser quand même
quelques problèmes d'éthique et il est
urgent que la france qui a aujourd'hui
reçu 500 mille doses
il paraît que la semaine prochaine on va
en avoir cinq cent mille nouvelles et
bien qu'on monte en puissance rapide
mais je crains fort que il y à une
latence qui risque de peser lourdement
sur l'état psychologique de nos
concitoyens une dernière question quand
vous voyez la campagne les campagnes de
vaccination s'accélère et ailleurs c'est
le cas on en parlait tout à l'heure avec
philippe froguel au royaume uni il ya ce
vaccin astrazeneca qui a été donc
autorisé là bas cela vous inquiète pour
les mois à venir en france on a un
système qui normalement oui j'ai juste
on a un système de santé qui est très
performant en france normalement et qui
est reconnu dans le monde entier et
c'est vrai que là on est au but et à une
problématique de stocks et de deux on
sait que dans beaucoup d'autres pays ont
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué le
vaccin qui vient de de russie d'autres
vaccins qui viennent d'angleterre wyss
le protège où ils se gardent pour eux on
n'a pas eu une stratégie peut-être de
d'anticiper les choses alors je n'ai pas
d'aller de faire surtout quand on est en
europe avec ses contraintes et ses
avantages mais beaucoup de contraintes
donc ça arrange pas forcément les choux
est vrai qu'en en europe on est fermée à
un vaccin spoutnik d un choc nerveux
le mot de la fin pour vous oh vous savez
ce n'est pas le mot de la fin
c'est plus exactement que le combat
continue que les maires vont se
mobiliser sur laval ce soir car nous
sommes au contact de la population
mais il faut aussi que nous ayons les
moyens et notamment ya pas que les
moyens de vaccin car il pourra se voir
aussi le personnel car dans un certain
nombre de villes
nous manquons vous le savez de médecins
et d'infirmières
donc j'espère qu'il va y avoir une
mobilisation va falloir faire revenir
sans doute les réservistes c'est à dire
les retraités pour qu'ils viennent
vacciner ça c'est un défi également qui
va qu'il va devoir être relevé mais bon
j'espère qu'on en sortira
le point jeunes majeurs c'est l'arrivée
des vaccins en nombre et en quantité en
france et là visiblement sata merci
beaucoup à vous jacques myard amer et
l'air de maisons laffitte
eric berline et mr génération terrain de
roche la molière dans la loire et dans
quelques instants
nous parlerons du bric 6 les députés
britanniques ont approuvé l'accord
conclu avec l'union européenne son
application provisoire est prévu le 1er
janvier dans l'attende une ratification
définitive par les eurodéputés
puis direction l'argentine ou le sénat a
approuvé le projet de loi légalisant les
vg et sans conditions jusqu'à la 14e
semaine de grossesse un jour historique
à rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
d'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
sb c'est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelque part
dans notre politique internationale vis
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement où en
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même la
france oubliée c'est une rencontre avec
ces citoyens qui ne se résignent pas à
la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suivrai
pas en appartement on est énervé donner
le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vois des remarques ont ils
fassent un tour de tracteur et cnooc une
grande campagne il faut savoir c'est
qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez 20h30 heure française ce
matin les dirigeants de l'union
européenne ont signé l'accord commercial
poste brixi boris johnson a signé le
texte après que les députés britanniques
l'ont approuvé à une écrasante majorité
la chambre haute du parlement doit en
débattre avant une promulgation par la
reine elizabeth ii son application est
prévue pour demain 23 heures heure
locale je vous propose d'écouter le
premier ministre britannique lors de la
signature du texte aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup à tous je veux que tout
le monde comprenne que le traité que je
viens de signer n'est pas la fin c'est
un nouveau départ et je pense que c'est
le début de ce qui sera une merveilleuse
relation entre le royaume uni et nos
amis et partenaires de l'union
européenne que je suis ravi d'accueillir
avec nous aujourd'hui au 10 downing
street
le voici et je sais que la question que
vous allez tous vous poser l ai je lu la
réponse est oui et c'est une excellente
affaire pour ce pays ainsi que pour nos
amis et partenaires de signature
historique pour un accord conclu après
de longues longues tractations
il aura fallu quatre ans pour que ce
divorce soit actée et retour sur les
grandes dates qui ont fait le break site
avec estelle marche
il aura fallu 59 ans 59 ans pour que
l'union européenne qui n'avait connu que
des vague d'adhésions depuis sa génèse
en 1957 soit contrainte de faire face à
sa première session car c'est
précisément le 23 juin 2016 que le
destin de l'ue bascule
ce jour là dans un référendum où le vote
en faveur de la sortie de l'union
remporte 51 9% des suffrages avec un
taux de participation s'élevait à 72 des
gueules 2% des inscrits les britanniques
ont dit adieu à lui eu un résultat qui
aboutit dans la foulée à la démission du
premier ministre conservateur david
cameron
je pense que le pays a besoin d'un
nouveau leader
les négociations avec l'union européenne
doivent se faire avec un nouveau premier
ministre
ce dernier laisse donc son fauteuil du
10 downing street que 13 juillet 2016 à
l'ancien ministre theresa may quelques
jours après bruxelles présente son
champion pour les négociations michel
barnier
cet ancien commissaire européen et
ministre a pour mission de mener à bien
le grec cite côté européen il entre en
fonction le 1er octobre 2016
c'est dans ce contexte que le lendemain
theresa may livre un discours dans
lequel elle expose sa vision du royaume
uni post break site
nous allons devenir un pays totalement
souverain et indépendant qui ne fera
plus partie d'une union politique et qui
ne sera plus dominé par des institutions
supranationales qu'ils peuvent
outre passé notre parlement et nos
tribunaux en mars 2010 est le parlement
britannique vote pour le déclenchement
du bric si tu t'es les amène active donc
l'article 50 du traité de lisbonne que
voici
tout est un membre peut décider
conformément à ses règles
constitutionnelles de se retirer de
l'union l'état membre qui décide de se
retirer notifie son intention au conseil
européen fin mars 2017 le polonais
donald tusk alors président du conseil
européen dhr soit la fameuse
notification de thé les a mais qui
activent l'article 50 le processus de
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne démarre officiellement
s'ensuivent deux longs cycles de
tractations des négociations qui durent
en tout 20 mois ce qui nous amène au 13
novembre 2018
le gouvernement britannique annonce
depuis bruxelles qu'un accord de sortie
a été trouvé mais teresa mais peinent à
convaincre une partie des parlementaires
de son camp l'accord est rejeté trois
fois de suite entre janvier et mars 2019
dans l'impasse theresa may démissionne
le 7 juin de la même année
j'ai fait tout mon possible pour
convaincre les parlementaires d'accepter
l'accord sur le breakbeat
malheureusement je n'y suis pas parvenu
malgré trois tentatives
je crois qu'il fallait persévérer même
si les chances de réussite étaient très
faibles
mais il est maintenant clair que dans
l'intérêt du pays un nouveau premier
ministre doit prendre le relais
annonce donc aujourd'hui que je
quitterai la présidence du parti
conservateur
le vendredi 7 juin afin qu'un nouveau
dirigeant puisse être désigné
quant au divorce il est reporté au 31
octobre 2019
entre temps boris johnson entre en scène
et devient un premier ministre le 23
juillet
en octobre 2019 boris johnson annonce
qu'un nouvel accord de sortie a été
trouvé de leur côté les 27 s'entendent
sur un nouveau report du bric site
il est fixé au 31 janvier 2020 le 9
janvier beaux jo comme il est surnommé
réussi là où theresa may avait échoué il
fait voter l'accord par les élus de la
chambre des communes
vingt-deux jours plus tard le royaume
uni est officiellement divorcée de
l'union européenne les deux parties
entre alors dans une période de
transition
les pilotes de ce divorce est fixée au
31 décembre 2020 mais les deux parties
ont toujours du mal à s'accorder trois
dossiers coince la pêche les garanties
de non concurrence voulue par lui et le
choix des institutions qui devront
trancher les éventuels futurs litiges
entre bruxelles et londres
les jours passent et les risques d'un
odile grandissent énième rebondissement
le 24 décembre les deux parties
s'entendent finalement à l'arraché the
deal et il donne déclare ainsi boris
johnson est ce qu'à lui je suis très
heureux de vous annoncer cet après midi
que nous avons conclu le plus gros
accord commercial à ce jour d'une valeur
de 660 milliards de livres sterling par
an un accord de libre échange global
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne
semblable à celui signé avec le canada
les disputes avec nos amis et
partenaires européens ont été parfois
intenses je pense que c'est une bonne
affaire pour toute l'europe et pour nos
amis et partenaires également un accord
qui met donc fin à quatre ans de longues
négociations et incertitudes
les deux parties ont à présent scellé
leur sort l'accord quant à lui doit être
ratifié par le parlement européen en
février prochain et nous retrouvons tout
de suite claude planches maison expert
en relations internationales
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous
alors à la veille de la sortie du
royaume-uni du marché unique européen
quels sont les dangers qui pourraient
mettre en péril un brick site ordonnée
alors on a un petit jean claude blanche
mais on vous avait perdu mais on vous a
retrouvé en aller et bien écoutez orgon
soir évidemment boris johnson donc à
déclarer l'urgence et a obtenu un vote
favorable de la chambre des communes où
il dispose d'une majorité confortable
avec parti conservateur
et puis de toute façon le leader de
l'opposition du parti travailliste avait
déclaré qu'il voterait également en
faveur de ce traité parce que la
population britannique ne comprendraient
pas bien un vote contraire donc ce vote
était acquis d'avancé il a été obtenu en
très peu de temps la chambre dès lors
est en train de suivre la reine donc
pourra ratifier probablement demain et
le traité entre en vigueur à titre
provisoire dès demain soir puisque les
27 chefs d'état et de gouvernement ont
signé par procédure écrite dans la
journée d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
donc il reste maintenant à faire
ratifier par les vingt-sept parlement ce
qui devrait pouvoir se faire assez
rapidement
il ya tout de même des formalités parce
que on peut pas confondre toujours
vitesse et précipitation et dans les
procédures il faut que ce texte qui et
écrire en anglais
dans un anglais d'ailleurs dit on qui
n'est pas toujours très juridique soit
réécrit par ce qu'on appelle à bruxelles
les juristes linguistes dans les 24
langues officielles de l'union
européenne et ça va prendre un petit peu
de temps ça va prendre quand même
quelques semaines et à partir de ce
moment là les 27 parlements nationaux
pourront
ratifiée restera le parlement européen
qui n'a pas beaucoup apprécié d'être
bousculés comme il a été ces jours ci et
qui veut examiner les deux mille pages
avec les annexes de ce traité et donc
encore une fois toutes les langues
officielles de l'union européenne
il y en a 24 donc ça prendra du temps et
le parlement européen a dit qu'il
pourrait se prononcer et probablement au
mois de mars
alors évidemment cd reste présente
toujours un petit risque parce que à un
débat peut peut apparaître
il peut y avoir des pêcheurs qui se
dispute avec des pêcheurs britannique
pendant les prochaines semaines il peut
y avoir des incidents aux frontières il
peut y avoir des problèmes à gibraltar
mais à priori il n'y a plus d'obstacle
et en effet ce traité sera ratifiée
entrera en vigueur à la fin du mois de
mars
alors quand même quels sont les dégâts
collatéraux d'un tel accord il y en a
quelques-uns le premier il était évident
et il fait partie du break site c'est à
dire que à partir de demain soir on
rétablira des contrôles douaniers aux
frontières du royaume uni ça veut dire
qu'il aura beaucoup moins de fluidité
dans les échanges ça veut dire aussi que
tous les animaux vivants seront soumis à
un contrôle sanitaire un contrôle
vétérinaire sur des points bien précis
de la frontière et que ceci va
évidemment probablement provoquer des
encombrements probablement même des
ruptures dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
parce que d'un côté comme de l'autre il
va falloir vérifier les déclarations
d'exportation les déclarations
d'importation et puis aussi vérifier
l'origine au sens soigner l'origine des
produits
et comme vous le savez il faut qu'un
produit et 40% de valeur ajoutée
localisé dans un pays pour qu'ils aient
l'origine de ce pays donc tout ça va
provoquer des contrôles
et puis le deuxième
motif de difficulté c'est que le royaume
uni on ne le dit pas beaucoup a souhaité
qu'un certain nombre de sujets soit en
dehors du traité c'est à dire qu'on n'en
parle pas tout simplement
alors c'est le cas des fameux services
financiers de la city où là bas c'est la
commission qui donnera ou ne donnera pas
un certificat d'équivalence aux grands
opérateurs financiers de la city pour
qu'ils puissent opérer sur le continent
et comme certains ne l'ont pas eh bien
ils ont ouvert des succursales sur le
continent à francfort à paris à dublin
ou à luxembourg pour pouvoir vendre les
produits financiers et les services
financiers qu'ils avaient l'habitude de
vendre à partir de londres
ça c'est un point assez important et je
crois que la city est assez mécontents t
elle le fera savoir par la suite il y a
aussi le fait ça c'est moins gênant
politiquement pour monsieur johnson qu'
il n'y aura plus de programmes erasmus
pour au royaume-uni et que par
conséquent les quelques trente mille
étudiants étrangers qui venaient étudié
au titre des races mousse dans les
universités britanniques soient ne
pourront plus faire parce que ce sera
trop cher soit passons par un autre
programme bilatéral qui sera mis en
place entre temps et puis autre secteur
qui est exclu de l'accord tout ce qui
concerne la sécurité et la politique
étrangère
alors on savait depuis longtemps que la
grande bretagne pour ça pour la sécurité
penchait plutôt du côté états unis et
fait pas elle fait d'ailleurs partie de
ce qu'on appelle le five c'est à dire
les cinq états unis canada australie
nouvelle zélande et au royaume uni pour
partager leur enseignement eh bien elle
le sera encore plus dans ce club que
dans celui des européens et tout cela
dernier point a effectivement très
important puisque on en a beaucoup parlé
aujourd'hui c'est gibraltar gibraltar et
depuis 10 713 un territoire britannique
et
le gouvernement britannique a dit ça
n'entre pas dans la négociation du break
site
nous en parlerons directement avec le
gouvernement de madrid alors c'est un
peu gênant comme l'a dit la ministre des
affaires étrangères espagnol parce que
chaque jour quinze mille espagnols
passent la frontière pour aller
travailler sur le rocher de gibraltar
qui d'ailleurs comporte environ 30000
habitants
donc ces travailleurs qui passent la
frontière chaque jour
c'est très important pour l'économie de
gibraltar et il serait très très
fâcheuses que la frontière soit fermé la
négociation est en cours elle n'a pas
encore abouti et il est possible qu'ils
la difficulté importante parce que par
ailleurs les britanniques naturellement
ne veulent pas que cette frontière
soient tenus par les espagnols sont
ouvertes par les espagnols puisqu'il
s'agit d'un territoire britannique et
ils ne veulent pas que ça penche du côté
ça penche un peu trop du côté espagnol
et puis par ailleurs il y a les
difficultés qui tiennent à l'ecosse
puisque la chief minister du
gouvernement écossais a dit très
clairement que il était probablement
autant pour les costes devenir un pays
indépendant de l'europe un pays européen
indépendant plus agréablement et bien
sûr londres refuse et refusera tout
nouveau référendum en écosse mais ça va
créer une tension politique d'ailleurs
les députés écossais du party snp ont
voté contre l'accord aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas très nombreux mais ils ont
tous voté contre
de la même façon en irlande du nord pour
éviter tout risque de rétablissement
d'une frontière physique entre l'irlande
du nord qui appartient au royaume uni et
la république d'irlande
on a imaginé dans le traité du break 6
d'il ya un an une annexe irlandaise qui
organise un système un petit peu
compliqué à savoir que l'irlande du nord
appliquera la réglementation
communautaire mais que par ailleurs elle
fera parti du marché unique britannique
et pour éviter qu'ils aient une
frontière entre les deux irlandais bien
les les douaniers britanniques feront
leur contrôle en mer entre
l'irlande du nord et le reste du royaume
uni ce qui est compliqué qui
probablement provoquera des difficultés
d'application importante
enfin s'agissant des étrangers les
quelques 4 millions d'européens qui
vivent en grande bretagne pourront y
rester c'est prévu dans le traité de
bréxent hit de l'année dernière en juin
ils devront chercher un certificat de
résidence
ça fait un principe qui sera délivré
automatiquement et pour les nouveaux
arrivants pour ceux qui vont arriver à
partir de 2021
eh bien on leur donnera une sorte de
permis à points de résidents grande
bretagne et ces points seront calculés
en fonction de l'âge du revenu il faut
voir revenu à eux un salaire annuel d'au
moins trente mille euros mais aussi de
la connaissance de l'anglais mais aussi
d'un contrat de travail et donc d'un
certain nombre de conditions très
restrictives qui permettront aux
britanniques de fermer le robinet
probablement de l'arrivée de nouveaux
européens sur leur territoire alors que
dans certaines spécialités l'économie
britannique en a besoin
donc tout cela ce sont en effet les
dommages collatéraux du break site et on
verra bien ce qui se passera dans les
prochains mois merci claude
blanchemaison je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales
l'avortement est désormais légal en
argentine après avoir été approuvé par
les députés la loi a été adopté par les
sénateurs avec 38 voix pour 29 contre et
une abstention jusqu'à présent les vg
n'était permis qu'en cas de viol ou de
danger pour la vie de la mère à
l'argentine devient l'un des rares pays
d'amérique latine à autoriser
l'intervention volontaire de grossesse
on voit cela avec un hymne illégaux
gâche un vote historique pour le pays
l'avortement est désormais légal jusqu'à
14 semaines
dès l'annoncé du résultat du vote au
sénat
des militantes pro avortement ont
manifesté leur joie je suis très ému
c'est un jour historique
aujourd'hui est un jour historique il
n'y a rien de plus à dire c'est un droit
acquis et on ne va pas s'arrêter là
ce n'est que le début je suis trop
contente je n'arrive pas à le croire je
vous jure c'est fou selon le
gouvernement jusqu'à 520 nilab ortement
clandestins sont pratiqués chaque année
dans le pays
trente-huit mille femmes sont
hospitalisée pour des complications
jusqu'à présent en vertu d'une loi
datant de 1921 lives et gêne était
autorisé qu'en cas de viol ou de danger
pour la vie de la mère un sujet qui crée
la division dans ce pays très catholique
l'église catholiques et les protestants
évangéliques avaient lancé un appel au
respect de la vie à naître
accompagné d'une journée de jeûne et de
prières alors pour les manifestants
anti-avortement
la nouvelle est difficile à accepter
nous continuerons à les défendre nous
continuerons chaque jour à nous battre
pour les femmes qui en ont le plus
besoin et pour les filles
je suis tellement féministe que je
défends les femmes des l'utérus
ces politiciens ne représentent pas la
majorité dans tous les sondages
les gens sont contre ils ne nous
représentent pas ils représentent
d'autres intérêts il y a deux ans le
sénat avait rejeté un texte similaire
mais afin de convaincre les sénateurs de
voter pour la possibilité pour les
médecins de faire valoir leur objection
de conscience a cette fois été incluse
dans la loi
au pouvoir depuis fin 2010 8
le président de centre gauche alberto
fernandez avait promis de soumettre à
nouveau la légalisation de l'ibg aux
parlementaires le chef de l'état a salué
une loi instaurant un avortement sur
légal et gratuit
avec ce texte l'argentine rejoint cuba
l'uruguay le guyana et la province de
mexico seuls en amérique latine à
autoriser l'avortement sans condition
et on en parle tout de suite avec
gabriella bravo journaliste spécialiste
de l'amérique latine
bonsoir à vous remercier à d'autres avec
non direct sur arte france donc c'est un
vote historique qui me fin on l'a vu
donc à un combat de très longue haleine
bon soit effectivement c'est un combat
qui sont menées les femmes sont
gentilles féministe ce argentine depuis
de longues années voire des décennies
pour avoir le droit à décider sur leur
propre corps mais comment c'est possible
que cette fois ci et son aboutie d'un il
ya le président monsieur fernandez qui
avait dit qu'il allait soutenir cette
proposition de loi et pendant sa
campagne présidentielle
les choses qu'il a fait aujourd'hui
d'après et le haillan deuxième point
c'est la ténacité des féministes des
femmes'' argentine qui pendant des
années et sans lutter pour pouvoir avoir
la légalisation de l'avortement mais
aussi qu'il soit gratuit ouvert à tous
les femmes
on a vu qu'ils sont occupé tout l'espace
possible l'espace public les médias les
réseaux sociaux on les a vus débarquer
même ici au festival de cannes dont ils
sont faits un travail de pédagogie
vraiment exemplaire et finalement ça
aboutit à qu'un certain nombre des
députés et des sénateurs en revue sa
position face à l'avortement
puisque malgré en dépit des ses
positions et religieuses ses positions
philosophiques
ils sont décidés de approuvé cette loi
pour des raisons de santé des santé
publique puisque milliers et milliers de
femmes à l'argentine fait céder saab
ortement clandestine donc aucun destin
dans le corps c'est il ya des raisons
aussi des santé publique derrière cette
légalisation
alors c'est un profond changement pour
la société argentine
qu'est-ce qui va maintenant comment ça
va évoluer c'est un changement pour la
société argentine mais ça peut donner
aussi ça ça peut donner l'exemple à
d'autres pays de l'amérique latine
il faut noir que le féminisme en
amérique latine et très protéiforme
d'un côté on a les féministes et des
communautés indigènes indigènes les
féministes anti racistes des colonials
les féministes même pour un changement
du système capitaliste pour les droits
des minorités sexuelles donc skipper
l'exemple qui donne l'argentine après un
combat des années qu'il a menée c'est
des pouvoirs donnés aux féministes de
tout l'amérique latine la possibilité
dès que ses propres combats qui ne sont
pas forcément la légalisation de
l'avortement
sinon le droit aux terres les droits à
avoir les mêmes salaires entre hommes
ces femmes et ces caisses et kamba
puisse voir la lumière dans les
prochaines années
on pense aussi par exemple au chili le
chili quand va écrire pour la première
fois de l'histoire de l'humanité une
constitution paritaire moitié homme
moitié femme
donc on voit que l'amérique latine la
lutte féministe commence à gagner une
grande place dans l'espace de l'amérique
latine et est ce que c'est un camouflet
pour l'église catholique très influente
en amérique latine
l'argentine qui le pays d'origine du
patron soit effectivement c'est un
camouflet pour l'église catholique parce
que mal grec en argentine et dans
d'autres pays
l'église est séparée de l'état les
risques continus a exercé une grande
influence sur certains politiques et
c'est surtout pas simple les politiques
d'avortement puisque l'amérique latine
c'est l'endroit au monde où c'est le
plus difficile qu'il femmes puissent
avorter
donc effectivement c'est un camouflé
parce que les grilles
l'église catholique a perdu énormément
de terrain après tout les scandales de
pédophilie qu'ils sont sortis à à la
lumière donc effectivement malgré
l'influencé du pape le papier argentin
on voit que c'est les mouvements sociaux
que en pris le dessus sur cette affaire
alors c'est une victoire pour les femmes
argentines toutes les femmes d'amérique
latine une victoire pour la société
argentine une victoire politique on en
parlait aussi pour le président de
centre gauche alberto fernandez qui a
beaucoup milité pour que ce projet
aboutisse
pour lui c'est une victoire politique il
va pouvoir surfer sur cette ferveur
désormais à son avantage effectivement
c'était une promesse de campagne
donc là la promesse a été tenue et
sûrement il faut voir que le féminisme
le mouvement féministe tout autant en
argentine qui est dans d'autres pays
comme le chili et le brésil et commence
à réunir énormément de monde donc les
politiques et comment ça s'est passé la
question réellement des pouvoirs comme
comme des alliances c'est aussi ces
femmes c'est la moitié de la population
c'est c'est des gens qui votent et qui
ne vont pas voter pour des gens
conservateurs ne vont pas voter
continuez à élire des gens qui ne
respecte pas ses propres soins le soin d
d d avoir le droit à son propre corps
donc quand il ya un changement qui
commence à s'exercer en temps en
argentique et dans d'autres pays de
l'amérique latine
merci beaucoup à vous gabriela bravo
journaliste spécialiste de l'amérique
latine et dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de l'évolution de l'épidémie
en france si la campagne de vaccination
a démarré le virus continue de circuler
le couvre feu devrait être avancée dans
certains départements à partir de samedi
et puis direction l'allemagne qui
enregistre un nombre record de décès
s'apprête à prolonger ces restrictions
contre le coc vite 19
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle en 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée que la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
ce sera inscrit au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
donc
[Musique]
des organes d'un flux ans de propagande
et de propagande mensongère du château
[Musique]
alors non mais vous êtes filmés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n'est pas fier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire rasé à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle créait un
incident
c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
les chinois ne sont pas des guerriers
ce sont avant tout des commerçants ils
ont négocié avec quinze pays
le partenariat régional économique
global qui crée la plus grande zone de
libre échange du monde
l'annnonce de sa signature par vidéo à
nike bouleverse les équilibres mondiaux
et consacre la perte d'influencé
américaine dans cette partie goût il est
clair qu'avec cet accord le pôle
économique mondiale tant au niveau du
développement que de l'attractivité est
dorénavant durablement installé sur le
continent asiatique avec son est
puissant tranche rendez vous compte un
espace économique occupé par 2 milliards
200 millions d'habitants qui représente
30% de la production mondiale de
richesse il est triste et même
inquiétant de constater que l'europe se
retrouve aujourd'hui marginalisée par
rapport à l'air super
[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information tout
de suite voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 30 décembre
les salles de spectacles et de cinéma il
est très probable qu'elle puisse rouvrir
le 7 janvier déclarations du
porte-parole du gouvernement à la veille
des voeux du président emmanuel macron
côté nouvelles mesures un couvre-feu
avancé de deux heures c'est ce
qu'envisage l'exécutif pour contenir
l'épidémie
là où le corona virus circule rapidement
la mesure elle sera applicable à partir
de samedi plusieurs élus dénoncent la
position attentiste du gouvernement et
pointe du doigt la lenteur de la
vaccination en france
[Musique]
l'allemagne confrontée à une forte
reprise de l'épidémie le pays enregistre
un nombre record de décès liés aux que
vides et s'apprête à prolonger ces
restrictions après le 10 janvier date
butoir du confinement partiel en vigueur
en russie
elles les autorités ont prévenu que
saint pétersbourg et est à un pas du
confinement est les bars et restaurants
et sont fermés pour les fêtes de fin
d'année chiant
[Musique]
2020 une année à oublier pour l'économie
avec le comique 19 la france a connu une
récession historique les tailles a
répondu par le quoi qu'il en coûte
de quoi limiter la casse pour l'instant
mais ces milliards d'argent public sont
ils une réponse à l'aggravation du
chômage nous verrons cela avec
l'économiste jacques sapir qui tentera
de nous éclairer tout à l'heure dans son
édito échos font presque deux mois après
la présidentielle donald trump eux
refusent toujours de concéder sa défaite
mais dans son camp certains commencent à
perdre patience en témoigne à ce vote
d'un grand nombre de républicains la
chambre des représentants en faveur du
budget de la défense auquel le président
américain a opposé son veto à camoufler
pour le locataire de la maison blanche
alors que le vote final au sénat doit
arriver d'ici la fin de la semaine
[Musique]
et on débute cette édition avec un point
sur les derniers chiffres du colis de 19
en france santé publique france dénombre
26 1457 cadeaux qu'ovide détecté en 24
heures en hausse depuis mercredi dernier
trois cent quatre personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital le taux de
positivité et s'établit désormais à 2,9
pour cent
l'exécutif qui reste sur ses gardes et
crainte un rebond de l'épidémie après
les fêtes de fin d'année le porte-parole
du gouvernement gabriela talent précise
d'ailleurs qu'il est très peu probable
que les salles de spectacles et de
cinéma puisse rouvrir le 7 janvier à
parmi les pistes envisagées par
l'exécutif pour contenir l'épidémie un
couvre-feu avancé de 18 heures à 20
heures là où le corona virus circule
rapidement la mesure serait applicable à
partir donc de ce samedi et puis côté
vaccins olivier verrons a défendu hier
la lenteur du démarrage de la campagne
de vaccination il s'agit selon lui de
prendre le temps de la pédagogie et
d'éviter les erreurs et pour en parler
on rejoint jean pierre pierre jean père
magnan il est président de l'uar ps
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé des médecins libéraux d'auvergne
rhônalpins
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors votre région
elle fait partie des zones rouges
d'abord quelle est la situation elle est
à peu près stable mais on est sur un
plateau qui augmente
papa de pas de vos confinement envisagé
pour l'instant mais un couvre-feu
annoncé est ce que selon vous c'est une
mesure utile oui oh vous savez on
l'avait demandé d'ailleurs on en avait
parlé sur votre antenne début novembre
ça fait deux mois qu'on devrait la voir
alors ça fait deux mois que vous devriez
la voir justement mais est ce que vous
vous étiez favorable à reconfirmer local
pas je pense qu'un reconfirme en local
est la seule manière de répondre on
l'avait demandé lors de la première
vague au printemps et on avait eu un
refus obstiné de l'exécutif de le mettre
en place ce résultat s'avère flambées en
particuliers sur le rhône et sur l'a2
avec le retour des évangélistes et on
n'a pas pu prendre de mesures ciblées
départemental et ça a été une des
grandes erreurs de la première vague de
grands films bon alors c'est vrai
qu'avec l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé libéraux de
votre région qui représente à peu près
14 mille médecins donc vous réclamiez
depuis assez longtemps quand même des
mesures immédiates draconiennes pour
enrayer la propagation de l'épidémie est
ce que vous avez le sentiment que
finalement c'est toujours la même
chanson que les médecins de ville de
province deux régions ne sont pas
entendus oui on n'est pas entendu si
vous voulez et en plus on a un épisode
maintenant qui se pointe qui est la
vaccination
la vaccination n'a été véritablement
pris à bras le corps par gouvernement
qu'à partir de début novembre
rien n'avait été préparé avant et ça
c'est une erreur colossale et on voir
payer le prix fort on est en train
d'inventer l'eau chaude avec le système
informatique de vaccination nationale
alors que sur étagère dans la région et
ainsi qu'en bourgogne franche comté en
nouvelles aquitaine on a déjà on va dire
un carnet de vaccination électronique
mais dans sa fin et on s'obstine à
vouloir avec la cnam inventer quelque
chose qui n'existe pas qui ne fonctionne
pas
c'est une des raisons pour le pl
actuellement il n'ya lenteur au
déploiement de la vaccination en france
parce que le système vaccinale
d'enregistrement n'est pas prêt parce
que les super congélateur ne sont pas
encore livrés on a pour l'instant trois
congélateurs de livrer dans notre région
on en aura huit à la fin de la semaine
on en attend au total 13 sur la région
c'est une impréparation mais colossal
vous allé dans le même sens que les élus
locaux qui plaide justement pour une
campagne de vaccination qui s'accélère
oui on plaide pour une campagne de
vaccination qui sert le problème c'est
que à force d'avoir venir louvoyer aussi
bien pour la gestion des masques puis la
gestion des tests maintenant il y à une
méfiance
moi quand je vois avec mes confrères
lorsque depuis lundi
la vaccination est quand même lancé
officiellement aucun patient ne veut se
faire vacciner
ils disent tous on n'a pas assez d'infos
et que leur répondent on vient juste
d'avoir nous avant-hier les données
qu'on peut aller télécharger sur finder
pour les effets secondaires les effets
secondaires qui sont d'ex ni pour
l'instant ce qui arrive derrière on les
connaît pas et donc qu'il ya une
méfiance actuellement il ya que 4
français sur 10 qui veulent se faire
vacciner ça répond alors il ya une
méfiance est vrai des français qui comme
vous le dites manque d'information mais
aussi on remarque qu'à une défiance
aussi au sein des personnels soignants
l'aîné le les professionnels de santé
qui sont divisés quand même sur sur la
question du vaccin alors divisés sur la
question du vaccin si vous voulez jouer
dimanche majorité des soignants croit la
vaccination
le problème c'est que dans ces vaccins
on n'a pas de recul sur les vaccins à m
donc méfiance de la chaîne du froid
était extraordinairement compliquée pour
l'instant je vous donne un exemple
caricatural
on n'a pas encore livré donc les super
congélateur
on en a 13 2 prévues sur la région après
il va falloir les certifier ce qui
explique la lenteur du déploiement de la
vaccination
on n'est pas du tout dans une situation
comme l'allemagne nous allons déjà
vacciner des dizaines de billets non
nous on a une administration française
qui est actuellement qui s'est une fois
de plus la démonstration on va dire
soyons clairs sur l'incompétence
on vous dit incompétent c'est ce que
pour vous on prend le chemin de ce qui
s'est passé notamment avec les quoi que
lorsqu'il était question justement de
tester massivement et qu'on n'y arrivait
pas parce qu'on n'était pas suffisamment
bien organisé on n'était pas
suffisamment bien organisés madame je
vous la corde mais surtout c'était une
décision qui venait d'en haut avec un
système où on n'avait pas de test il a
fallu qu'on en commande à tour de bras
et si je prends l'exemple de la région
vers rhône-alpes récemment le conseil
régional à l'ancienne campagne de
vaccination qui a été massive et qui a
très bien marché pourquoi parce qu'elle
était faite par les acteurs locaux
les professionnels de santé libéraux s'y
sont impliqués il y avait presque un
médecin
libéral sur six qui a donné de son temps
alors on est déjà surchargé c'est une
pleine période on va dire hivernale avec
la grippe
le retard des pathologies mais les
infirmiers sont brisés les pharmaciens
sont mobilisé les sapeurs pompiers de la
région
caen s'est décentralisé ça marche quand
ça vient d'en haut ça ne marche pas on
abandonne encore cet exemple nous avons
un carnet de vaccination électronique
qui marchent en auvergne rhône-alpes
on va nous imposer un système parisien
la première réunion comprenait bien la
chose suivante
la première réunion pour métro plan
mettre au point un système de
vaccination informatique a été lancé le
17 novembre 2020
est ce que vous trouvez normal que
l'épidémie à démarré en janvier 2020
qu'on commence à se préoccuper de lancer
un outil informatique avec les cadets
l'époque qu'on va avoir
minogue en 2020 c'est inacceptable dans
les régions à dans la région qui vous
concerne et les autres 6 1 qui sont
situés en zone rouge
donc voilà est-ce que vous estimez que
les mesures elles sont pas suffisamment
stricts et cela peut nous mener ou
finalement est ce qu'on va pouvoir
éviter une signer un troisième
confinement je ne sais pas si on aura le
confinement est une décision politique
ce que l'on ne l'a pas éviter c'est la
troisième vague ça c'est clair
elle est déjà quasiment présent à 25
mille nouveaux cas par jour comme vous
l'avez mis sur votre antenne c'est
flagrant avec un taux de positivité à
plus de 2,5 l'épidémie n'a fait que
croître et embellir sur la bourgogne
franche comté où certains départements
de la région
le couvre-feu à 18h illogique ça va et
obligé on va dire les gens à rentrer
même avec une mesure dérogatoire
directement chez eux et casser on va
dire le mélange de population qui
hantent qui fait le on va dire
l'avantagent de la propagation de cette
pandémie
donc qu'est ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui aux autorités par rapport à
la situation que vous vivez vous au
quotidien et les observations sur le
terrain
grosse que je le redis c'est très simple
c'est écouter on va dire le terrain
écouter les acteurs locaux les acteurs
régionaux utiliser le carnet de
vaccination électronique n'essayez pas
de rêve
thello chose avec ils ont fait passer le
décret sur le système informatique de
vaccination le 25 décembre
est ce que vous croyez logique que jonah
l'officiel essayent d'inventer la poudre
le 25 décembre le jour de la fête de
noël lambert fin on marche sur la tête
en france on a un carnet de vaccination
qui marche il faut convaincre les gens
la vaccination pour la population
générale c'est probablement avec les
retards qui sont en train de peindre
c'est pour avril
on a trois mois pour les convaincre pour
convaincre la population
janvier février mars il faut déployer le
carnet de vaccination électronique
il faut faire un travail de pédagogie la
raison va provenant le faire parce que
va dire est qu'ils sont on va dire un
peu plus réactif et heureusement pour
nous et heureusement pour la population
de la région envers donald mais je suis
très très inquiet si vous voulez sur le
sur l'efficacité d'une vaccination qui
pour l'instant n'est pas accepté par
majeur de la majorité de nos concitoyens
et on n'en prend pas le chemin
on n'en prend pas le chemin merci
beaucoup pierre-jean terme à nyon
président de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé et médecin
d'auvergne et rhône alpes
merci en allemagne à présent plus de
1100 morts en 24 heures là bas j'avais
le pays n'avait déploré autant d'eau des
faits liés au co lead en une seule
journée depuis le début de la pandémie
et face à cette deuxième vague très
virulente
berlin envisage de prolonger ses mesures
de restrictions sanitaires est les
détails c'est avec solène gones à une
fin d'année qui signe un triste record
en allemagne plus de 1100 morts en 24
heures à cause du coffee de 19 ce
mercredi avec des chiffres de
contamination qui ne baisse quasiment
plus depuis une semaine plus de 22 mille
nouveaux cas ont été détectés en un jour
des chiffres loin de permettre de lever
les gestes barrière ces chiffres
montrent une fois de plus à quel point
ce virus est brutale les infections et
le nombre de décès montre également que
nous sommes encore très loin de la
normalité dans laquelle nous
souhaiterions vivre
en tête des régions les plus touchées la
saxe particulièrement réfractaires aux
mesures de restriction viennent ensuite
la bavière le brandebourg ou encore
berlin dans ces länder
la fermeture des commerces non
essentiels des écoles et le télétravail
en vigueur depuis déjà quinze jours
n'ont toujours pas montré leur
efficacité
la nouvelle variante du coronavirus plus
contagieuse détectés au royaume uni
pourrait être responsable de la
virulence de l'épidémie ces dernières
semaines ce mardi les autorités ont
annoncé qu'elles étaient présentes dans
le nord du pays dès le mois de novembre
submergé par la deuxième vague de
coronavirus l'allemagne a démarré
dimanche dernier sa campagne de
vaccination priorité aux seniors et
personnel soignant
soixante mille personnes ont reçu les
premières doses berlin assure qu'il
disposera de 3 à 4 millions de doses
d'ici fin janvier
en attendant l'allemagne envisage de
prolonger le confinement partiel au delà
du 10 janvier
la chancelière fédérale angela merkel
présente ses voeux pour l'année 2000 21
ce jeudi un discours qui pourrait bien
prendre la lure de voeux de
rétablissement
l'allemagne où s'est déroulée une
manifestation déco vide sceptiques
aujourd'hui dans la capitale
ils protestaient notamment contre
l'obligation de porter le masque une
mobilisation initialement interdite par
les autorités en raison de l'épidémie le
tribunal administratif de berlin a
rejeté
ce mercredi un recours déposé contre
l'interdiction de se regrouper
la police a finalement encadrer les
manifestants on va en parler tout de
suite avec rhône et sébastien bauer et
les médecins spécialistes en chirurgie
générale et expertise médicale bonsoir
un run et sébastien bauer merci d'être
avec nous alors on voit que là il ya
quand même de la grogne on en allemagne
face aux mesures de restriction oui nos
vols l'allemagne est aujourd'hui dans
une situation un peu comparable à celle
de la france il y a deux mois on a pris
un peu de retard par rapport aux mesures
là qu'il fallait prendre mais finalement
la situation n'est pas tellement
différente de celle de la france
nous avons aujourd'hui quand même les
premiers effets positifs des mesures qui
ont été prises depuis dix jours
le chiffre de réinfection est quand même
nettement inférieur aujourd'hui d'après
les chiffres actuels il est de 0,5 et
quelques
donc oui on est dans un problème
européen et les problèmes sont à peu
près les mêmes qu'en france ce que vient
de dire mon prédécesseur pour la région
rhône alpes c'est vrai ici il ya
également des couacs pour les problèmes
de réfrigération des des piqûres à faire
est de dire que je ne suis plus en
france rené sébastien bauer
non non vous suis très très bien juste
cette question sur la nouvelle souche
mutante qui serait présente dans votre
temps en allemagne depuis le mois de
novembre
quels sont vos connaissances sur ce
virus mutant sur sa progression c'est
fâcheux parce que ce qui me manque c'est
une régulation européenne pour
déterminer les critères ils les
statistiques
l'allemagne a un seul laboratoire
capable de classifier le virus qui est
un hôpital de charité à berlin
donc très probablement on a pendant
longtemps on n'a pas enregistré le fait
que cette nouvelle que d'une mutation du
coronavirus a déjà était présente et
c'est très dommage parce qu'évidemment
cela empêche les différents pays de
prendre les mesures adéquates
on aurait probablement pu se passer de
la fermeture des frontières vis-à-vis de
la grande-bretagne parce que de l'autre
côté
le problème aurait été le même vous
pensez que vous pensez que la présence
de cette souche mutante sur le sol
allemand depuis assez longtemps
maintenant depuis plusieurs semaines
elle est responsable de ce que pourrait
être responsable de la situation
épidémique en rebond c'est tout à fait
spéculatifs les résultats des examens ne
sont pas encore définis nous le saurons
faire face
on peut y penser mais ce n'est pas
garanti je crois que le fait essentiel
c'est la discipline des gens qui
commencent en avoir marre de toute cette
affaire qui diminue surtout chez les
jeunes c'est très difficile il faut bien
se rendre compte que l'allemagne est
entourée de pays voisins alors que la
france quand même beaucoup de frontières
maritimes des poissons de l'atlantique
ne sont pas contagieux ça change a pu
les données mais sur le plan global
global
la france est dans le même pétrin que
l'allemagne
et que pensez-vous dé la gestion de
cette crise par la chancelière angela
merkel il ya des mesures de restriction
qui ont été prises à la mi décembre dont
un confinement partiel qui sera effectif
au moins jusqu'au 10 janvier
ce que sont
mini décembre à ce que c'était trop tard
dit selon vous c'était probablement trop
tardif de réagir maintenant il faut voir
que l'allemagne est un pays fédéral
c'est-à-dire la chancelière n'a pas les
mêmes moyens train président de la
république en france pour prendre des
décisions les décisions se prennent au
niveau des länder et là il ya eu des
réticences évidemment il ya des länder
qui sont bien moins touché surtout dans
le nord et qui n'ont pas envie de
prendre les mêmes décisions tout aussi
strict ce que la bavière audace axe
alors vous faisait tout à leur addition
justement la vaccination le rythme de
cette campagne de vaccination en
allemagne
c'est un peu similaire à sif paf en
france comment se déroule tel un peu de
la même façon il y adéquat auquel il
faut s'attendre on peut pas toujours
faire des reproches
l'administration c'est une situation
tout à fait nouvelle et il faudra avoir
un peu de patience
de toute façon ça prendra probablement
plusieurs mois pour avoir un effet sur
le nombre de cas installer le nombre de
décès mais vous pensez que en allemagne
il peut y avoir un changement de
stratégie dans la manière de mener cette
campagne de vaccination et et de m
peut-être que les autorités vont mettre
un coup d'accélérateur élargir cette
campagne non parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de limitations techniques qui est
qu'ils sont insurmontables la courte
accord à court terme et c'est le maillot
des transports c'est la production c'est
les instrumentations nécessaire pour
merci merci à vous et merci à vous rené
sébastien bauer prenez soin de vous vous
êtes un petit peu malade médecin
spécialiste en chirurgie
les expertises médicales merci pour cet
éclairage on va prendre maintenant la
direction de saint-pétersbourg en russie
la situation sanitaire y est assez
délicate comparée à d'autres régions les
autorités réagissent donc en serrant la
vis au niveau des mesures de restriction
ont fait le point sur place avec antoine
claireaux c'est un rêve pour beaucoup
que de venir passer les fêtes de fin
d'année à saint pétersbourg et pourtant
la situation sanitaire est
particulièrement délicate dans sept
régions de russie la situation à saint
pétersbourg est compliqué mais sous
contrôle
néanmoins le soutien du centre fédéral
et la coopération avec le blast de
leningrad nous ont donné de tels
résultats que nous tenons bon de manière
générale mais je fais toujours appel aux
habitants de la ville
la pandémie et la lutte contre la
pandémie relève de la responsabilité
mutuelle des autorités de l'état et des
habitants
les autorités promulguer des lois
organise le processus de traitement mais
les citoyens doivent également respecter
les règles prescrites par le rose poudré
de noces d'or
résultat les autorités locales ont
adopté des mesures assez radical comparé
au reste du pays du 30 décembre au 3
janvier
bars et restaurants sont fermés à la
clientèle alors qu'ils étaient jusque-là
ouverts jusqu'à 19 heures même chose
pour les théâtres et les musées
cette année très dure pour le secteur de
la restauration
il ya normalement beaucoup de clients
dans les restaurants et partout surtout
pendant les jours fériés les gens
affluent peut-être que les restrictions
contribueront à limiter l'augmentation
du nombre des cas mais en même temps la
restauration est durement frappée cette
année cette période est assez difficile
puisque nous venons de sortir de la
crise du printemps lors de laquelle nous
n'avons pas travaillé durant trois mois
et maintenant nous sommes autorisés à
travailler au moins comme ça franchement
nous sommes reconnaissants au moins pour
cette période
néanmoins pas de quoi entamer la bonne
humeur et l'enthousiasmé de la
population alors que se profilent les
fêtes du noël russe
on ira chez les parents de ma petite
amie apps cov et fêteront le nouvel an
en famille
nous allons faire la fête à la maison en
famille
nous avons nos enfants on restera chez
nikko brink cette année nous on avait
trois personnes et nous n'irons nulle
part à cause du coronavirus oui on a
peur la pandémie de qovu 19 que traverse
le monde ne touche pas la russie de
façon uniforme les autorités ajuste donc
les mesures à prendre en fonction du
contexte sanitaire local est à l'heure
actuelle c'est probablement à saint
pétersbourg que les mesures sur les plus
restrictifs dans quelques instants un
nous parlerons de la france qui a connu
une récession historique en 2020 à cause
du coït 19s une année à oublier pour
l'économie jacques sapir tentera de
répondre à cette question et puis
direction les états unis le budget
américain de la défense a été votée
donald trump a été désavoué par une
centaine de représentants républicains à
rester avec nous sur les france
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçons et lamont les actes
et je trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même la
france oubliée c'est une rencontre avec
ces citoyens qui ne se résignent pas à
la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même s'ils
auraient pas en appartement on est
énervé donner le sentiment qu'il faut à
chaque fois se battre ils vivent parfois
au bord des routes nationales pas
forcément loin de paris mais toujours
loin de ceux qui les dirigent
moi j'en ai marre qu'on y passe un tour
de tracteur etc nous payerons campagne
il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
et
quelle image il laisse de lui diego
maradona en argentine il laisse une
image bas d'une icône absolue d'un dieu
vivant parce que il a porté très haut
les couleurs d'un pays qui était
humiliée par la guerre des malouines ce
pays a gagné la coupe du monde alors
c'est pas une victoire militaire mais
c'est une revanche politique et sportif
sur une défaite militaire parce que la
politique et le sport font finalement
bon ménage
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique il c'était un homme
d'ultragauche on connaît sa proximité
avec castro on connaît sa proximité avec
hugo chavez
il avait cette sensibilité de toujours
incarné bien les dix khamis à dos les
sans-chemise il a toujours joué dans des
clubs qui incarnait la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central
vous êtes en train de dire finalement
diego maradona c'est l'homme du passé ce
cap a un côté paradoxal le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que le personnage
n'est pas lisse et qui a tout petit
aspect riz thé et c'est pour ça que
c'est un personnage de légende
où
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sens du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
dignité gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
les chinois ne sont pas des guerriers
ce sont avant tout des commerçants ils
ont négocié avec quinze pays
le partenariat régional économie globale
qui crée la plus grande zone de libre
échange du monde l'annnonce de sa
signature par vidéo à hanoi bouleverse
les équilibres mondiaux et consacre la
perte d'influencé américaine dans cette
partie nous il est clair qu'avec cet
accord le pôle économique mondiale tant
au niveau du développement que de leur
activité est dorénavant durablement
installé sur le continent asiatique avec
son est puissant tranché rendez vous
compte un espace économique occupé par 2
milliards 200 millions d'habitants qui
représente 30% de la production mondiale
de riz qu il est triste et même
inquiétant de constater que l'europe se
retrouve aujourd'hui marginalisée par
rapport à l'air super
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez 21h30 heure française
2020 une année à oublier pour l'économie
avec le colis de 19 la france a connu
une récession historique à laquelle
l'état a répondu par le quoi qu'il en
coûte
de quoi limiter la casse pour l'instant
mais ces milliards d'argent public sont
ils une réponse pérenne à l'aggravation
du chômage
après tout notre économie était
peut-être déjà malade avant la pandémie
on va en parler tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir à bonsoir à
jacques
merci d'être avec nous on soir samantha
alors jacques soit samantha et quelle
année donc 2020 pour l'économie est ce
qu'on peut comment fait à en tirer le
bilan réellement oui on peut tout à fait
et c'est effectivement une année
extrêmement difficile l'économie
française comme d'ailleurs l'ensemble
des autres économies mais peut-être plus
particulièrement l'économie française a
été frappé de plein fouet par la crise
sanitaire
alors bien sûr le choc de cette crise a
été en partie atténuée par l'action de
l'état et vous avez tout à fait raison
de citer le quoi qu'il en coûte prononcé
par emmanuel macron dans son discours du
mois de mars
néanmoins il est très clair aussi que
certains secteurs ont été plus
particulièrement touchées et mettront
vraisemblablement des années à se
relever justement ça te crise sanitaire
at elle été un choc aussi majeur qu'on
le prétend jacques oui absolument
absolument samantha on a connu pendant
l'année et 2020 un recul du pib donc du
produit intérieur brut entre -11 et -12%
c'est sans précédent même pendant la
crise de 1929
on n'avait pas eu un tel chiffre sur une
telle année maintenant ce qu'il faut
dire aussi et c'est un point important
et on va le voir justement sur ce
graphique c'est que en réalité la
croissance française et la consommation
avait arrêté de croître dès le troisième
voire le quatrième trimestre de l'année
donc ce qui est extrêmement un frappe en
aussi c'est le fait que cette crise
sanitaire elle n'est venue frapper une
économie qui n'allait pas bien qui était
déjà malade
alors est-ce que la france finalement
elle sentir plus mal que ses voisins
on peut le penser on peut le penser
effectivement ça mantin si on regarde
les chiffres comparatifs
on va voir que la france comme l'italie
sont des pays qui ont été plus
particulièrement frappé par cette crise
alors on sait que l'italie avait des
problèmes économiques extrêmement
important avant mais on voit que la
france et l'italie sont parmi les pays
qui ont le plus plongé inversement
l'allemagne s'en tire moins mal on voit
que nous sommes sous la moyenne de la
zone euro et l'ours qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir que les états
unis dont pourtant la gestion de la
crise sanitaire sont très très loin
d'être exemplaire on avait beaucoup de
critiques à nodal trump là dessus et
bien les états unis en fait s'en tire
nettement mieux que nous dans ces
conditions jacques or on imagine le
chômage il aurait dû exploser
oui effectivement
effectivement et ce qui a permis de
d'éviter que le chemin qu'ils
n'explosent pour l'instant c'est bien
entendu les mesures de chômage partiel
ceci étant il faut voir si on regarde
les données de pôle emploi que
l'ensemble des catégories qui représente
le chômage réel ce qu'on appelle dans le
langage de pôle emploi ou de la dares
les catégories à b et d et bien envoya
une très nette pic au moment du premier
confinement par contre les catégories c
e qui représente les quasi chômeurs
diminue pourquoi parce que ils ont été
absorbés dans les catégories à b et d et
l'ours qui est très intéressant c'est de
voir que évidemment dans la période qui
va suivre le premier confinement il ya
une baisse
du nombre des véritables chômeurs mais
cette baisse ne fasse pas le pic du mois
d'avril
on voit que l'on va rester visiblement à
un niveau élevé et cela s'est bien
entendu sans les résultats du 2ème
confinement et sans évidemment l'effet
de l'arrêt du système de chômage partiel
qui se produira très probablement dans
les prochaines parle du chômage ac 1
cela nous amène aux jeunes directement
menacés les jeunes qui ont payé un lourd
tribut à la crise
oui oui c'est absolument évident les
jeunes aussi on appelle jeunes 10 ans
les demandeurs d'emploi entre 18 et 30
ans c'est vraiment la catégorie qui a
été le plus touché on le voit alors
c'est la catégorie qui est le plus
touché par le choc du confinement au
mois d'avril
c'est aussi la catégorie qui est
peut-être le plus aidé le plus sensible
justement aux mesures du chômage partiel
néanmoins avec non pas la fin mais
disons la restriction du chômage partiel
après le premier confinement et bien on
voit que la courbe des demandeurs
d'emploi de 18 à 30 ans remontez remonte
de manière nettement plus significative
que par exemple pour les 30 60 ans pour
les 30-50 ans pour les 51 65 ans donc
les mesures prises par l'état ont permis
d'éviter le pire
oui ça il faut le dire le système du
chômage partiel a joué le rôle je dirais
d'un amortisseur extrêmement puissant
ceci étant ce qu'a fait la france n'est
pas en réalité différent de ce qu'on
fait de nombreux autres pays européens
il suffit de regarder par exemple sur
les sources du fonds monétaire
international
on voit que l'aide aux emplois ce n'est
le soutien aux emplois et il a même été
plus important en proportion évidemment
en italie qu'il ne l'a été en france
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
de voir que en france avec la fin du
premier confinement il
tombe très vite alors que dans de
nombreux autres pays comme par exemple
l'italie l'allemagne voire la belgique
eh bien il va se maintenir dans la
période d'après le premier confinement
alors c est jack
elle ne concerne pas tous les emplois
oui tout à fait et samantha il fait bien
le préciser il ya la fois les aides qui
concerne évidemment les salariés ce sont
eux qui sont éligibles au chômage
partiel
et puis il ya les aides qui vont être
plutôt sur les travailleurs indépendants
et les auto entrepreneurs
alors là ce qui est intéressant c'est
que on a mixé si vous voulez les deux
données qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit là
encore que l'italie fait à peu près la
même chose que nous nous ne sommes
réellement différent que par les aides
qui ont été attribuées aux salariés ou
donc aux employés pour ce qui est des
indépendants des pays que l'italie
l'allemagne
mais même par exemple l'espagne ont fait
nettement mieux que nous alors tout ça
évidemment à un coup oui oui bien sûr
bien sûr samantha c'est justement la
question du quoi qu'il en coûte bien sûr
cela aura un coût
et on sait déjà que normalement la dette
publique française qui étaient autour de
99 % à la fin de l'année dernière eh
bien elle va se situer à la fin 2020
entre 116 et 120 % donc oui ça a un coût
mais là encore et il faut le souligner
la france n'a pas été le pays qui a le
plus aidé son économie à trois pays qui
ont aidé plus l'économie que nous et
c'est là encore c'est extrêmement
intéressant de voir l'italie qui a un
système qui est pas si différent du
nôtre
l'allemagne et le royaume uni le royaume
uni que l'on présente très souvent comme
un modèle de société libérale et bien
non il a fait plus d aides que la france
en conclusion est ce qu'on peut
véritablement parler d'une année noire
ah oui certainement
certainement et cette année je pense que
nous serons de très nombreux à vouloir
l'oublier a pour de très nombreuses
raisons les restrictions à la liberté
dans la vie quotidienne mais aussi pour
les questions économiques
maintenant il faut savoir que dans cette
année noire et bien certains secteurs
ont été beaucoup plus touchés que
d'autres
il ya évidemment le secteur de
l'aéronautique pas seulement le secteur
des transports aériens mais aussi le
secteur de la construction aéronautique
airbus et un très gros employeurs en
france après tout nous sommes le real
perd d'airbus il faut toujours le
rappeler
jusqu'au secteur du tourisme le secteur
du que du petit commerce a aussi été
très largement touchés je ne parle même
pas du secteur de la culture qui est
complètement sinistré oui effectivement
c'est une année qui a été extrêmement
difficile et la question de savoir
comment nous relèverons non pas en 2021
mais plutôt en 2022 en 2023 elle est
aujourd'hui posée oui c'est vrai vous
avez raison à jacques j'aimerais pouvoir
dire que c'est une année vite à oublier
n'est pas sûr effectivement comme vous
le dites que 2020 soit une sinécure et
vient bien sûr vous reviendrez nous ont
parlé l'année prochaine à bientôt
jacques merci la fin du mandat de donald
trump ressemble à un chemin de croix de
plus en plus d'élus républicains
reconnaissent à la victoire de joe biden
à la présidentielle pire certains
membres de sa majorité ont voté contre
le veto qu'il a tenté d'opposer au
budget de la défense
reportage est signée dimitri scission
par 3 132 votes pour et 87 voix contre
la majorité des deux tiers est attentes
le projet de loi est donc adopté les
objections du président sont donc
rejetées
le greffier va aviser le sénat de
l'action de la chambre
par ce vote la chambre des représentants
rejettent le veto de donald trump au
prochain budget de la défense et fait un
nouveau pas vers l'adoption de ce texte
si cette nuit le sénat où les
républicains détiennent une courte
majorité rejettent aussi ce veto ce sera
une grande première sous le mandat de
donald trump est un camouflet inédit
jusqu'ici les deux chambres n'ont jamais
réuni assez de votes pour outrepasser le
veto présidentiel n'est posée à huit
reprises depuis quatre ans cette fois ci
l'enjeu semble transcender les
oppositions partisanes
le président trump a noté à juste titre
que le budget de la défense présentée
cette année n'inclut pas toutes les
mesures que nous républicain aurions
voulu je ne doute pas que nos collègues
démocrates pensent la même chose mais
c'est le cas chaque année
pour les courageux hommes et femmes des
forces armées des états unis l'échec
n'est simplement pas une option
donc lorsque c'est à notre tour au
congrès de les soutenir
nous ne pouvons pas échouer j'encourage
mes collègues à soutenir ce budget une
nouvelle fois lorsque nous voterons
demain le président américain refuse ce
budget car il permet le changement de
nom de base militaire honorant des
généraux partisans de l' esclavage mais
aussi parce qu'il réduit la possibilité
de retirer des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan d'allemagne et de corée du
sud
comme souvent c'est par un tweet donald
trump a marqué son désaccord
nos formidables soldats ne pourront pas
être retirés de pays étrangers qui ne
font rien pour nous négocié un meilleur
projet de loi où trouver de meilleurs
dirigeants maintenant le sénat ne
devrait pas approuver le budget de la
défense tant qu'il n'est pas améliorée
le vote du sénat aura lieu cette nuit
autre habitude de donald trump à la
veille de ce vote crucial
il a été aperçu en train de se rendre
sur le parcours de golf qu'il possède en
floride
et pour en parler à nous sommes en
direct depuis houston avec dave perkins
animateur radio à la liste apolitique et
partisan de donald trump c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir à vous dave perkins à merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rtl
france dont encore on revient évidemment
sur le vote
de nombreux républicains en faveur de ce
budget pour la défense auquel donald
trump avait opposé son veto que se
passe-t-il donald trump il lâché par par
les siens ça y est les rats quittent le
navire maintenant je pense que le
congrès n'a jamais été un grand soutien
de donald trump pour l'appareil
législatif là à garder à distance a
toujours souhaité sonder son départ du
côté républicain ou démocrate au sein de
la chambre et du sénat parce que se
présente un jamais fait ce qu'il voulait
lui faire faire la plupart des membres
du congrès considère que donald trump
est en fin de mandat sera parti d'ici à
un mois
et ils veulent donc rétablir le système
qui leur était bénéfique que donald
trump a essayé de supprimer que donald
trump a promis et de supprimer lors de
sa campagne électorale en 2007 c'était
une de ses grandes promesses électorales
il a dit qu'il allait ramener les
soldats de sérieux n'avait pas besoin
d'être où il ne faisait pas de
différence et de réutiliser toutes ces
dépenses de les réorienter vers d'autres
objectifs plus utile et donald trump a
rapatrié beaucoup de soldats de beaucoup
de missions qui n'étaient pas
justifiable et je pense que le complexe
industriel militaire s'apprête à
relancer la dépense permanente d'argent
le déploiement des troupes à l'étranger
ce qui s'est dépensé autant d'argent qui
finit dans les poches de politiciens et
d'industriels c'est une ressource qui
leur a bien manqué au cours des quatre
dernières années et qu'ils sont heureux
de pouvoir relancer ce flux de mener
maintenant que maintenant que donald
trump va bientôt partir ça veut dire
qu'al la fin du mandat de donald trump
s'annonce vraiment difficile il doit
céder
le pouvoir à joe biden au mois de
janvier je ne pense pas que cela sera
difficile je pense que donald trump fait
de son mieux pour utiliser le pouvoir
dont il dispose encore pour honorer les
promesses qui lui reste à honorer son
expression est souvent chaotique on a du
mal à le suivre mais je pense que c'est
une façon pour lui de mettre ses
opposants sur la défensive et il réussit
à obtenir ses objectifs beaucoup plus de
personnes pensent qu'il est déjà parti
il est plus difficile maintenant pour
lui de réussir mais je pense
effectivement en l'occurrence que ce
veto va être contournée et cela
permettra aux peuples de deux foires de
repérer les personnes qui leur poseront
des problèmes à l'avenir au sein de
l'administration
donald trump fait de son mieux et ces
gens essayent maintenant de le pousser
au bord du gouffre c'est l'argent qui
parle et on est en train de revenir à
l'ancienne façon de faire les choses
donc il y aura une lutte autour de cela
à long terme
ça veut dire que le sénat va aller dans
le même sens
senna je le pense on va vouloir
contourner ce veto car je ne pense pas
que de la trempe de beaucoup de soutien
au sein du sénat
il faudrait une majorité de deux tiers
et comme l'a presque la quasi majorité
du sert et à constituer des démocrates
alors ils seront le besoin d'un très
léger nombre de républicains et il ya
des républicains qui ont affirmé à
plusieurs reprises leur mépris quand
donald trump et n'hésiteront pas à voter
contre se lever tôt j'ai du mal à suivre
ce qui se passe c'est donc j'essaye de
suivre mais je pense effectivement que
donald trump se verra contrer dans les
deux chambres
alors on disait donald trump lâcher ou
pas par son camp le vice président
américain lui a refusé de donner son
aval à la nuit initiatives de certains
républicains qui cherchent à faire
annuler la certification de la victoire
de joe biden par le congrès le 6 janvier
prochain
est ce que c'est le signe d'une rupture
entre mike pence et donald trump
je pense que mike pence et donna trompe
reste cohérent restent proches et je ne
pense pas que le vice-président
l'abandonner ne serait ce que d'un pour
cent
[Musique]
les soutiens de donald trump le reste à
ses côtés quelle que soit l'opinion
générale est et je dois me rend fier
d'être un de ses soutiens je peux vous
garantir que quelles que soient les
actions de donald trump à l'avenir mike
pence n'est pas si important dans ce
contexte c'est vraiment donald trump qui
est au centre de cet élan et je ne pense
pas que les soutiens de donald trump
vont se décourager vont perdre leur
enthousiasme pour donald trump et pour
son programme cela va continuer c'est le
plus grand mouvement de l'histoire de la
politique américaine depuis un siècle
c'est très grand et cela va rester
important alors vous êtes un soutien de
donald
un peu donc vous vous continuez à le
soutenir mais vu de l'extérieur c'est
vrai que cette défiance présumé de miles
peines à son égard ça pourrait aussi
révéler une perte de crédibilité de
donald trump dans le champ politique
américain cela peut révéler des
difficultés mais pour ma peine c'est pas
pour donald trump l'opinion des gens
envers tel ce n'est pas très importante
mike pence lui-même n'est pas si
important que cela il l'a pas vraiment
beaucoup d'importance en tant que
candidat futur et donald trump a choisi
un ris président il a choisi un bon vice
président si le vice président on doit
mettre de la distance entre lui même et
donald trump cela va être
au grand dam de nos peines et pas de
donald trump ou de ses soutiens selon
vous l'avenir du tropisme a encore de
beaux jours devant lui pour le mouvement
ou pour l'homme donne c'est certain va
rester une super star des médias une
personnalité à l'horizon pour les
démocrates qui au cours des quatre
prochaines années et pourrait être à
nouveau candidat en 2024
il aura le pouvoir nécessaire le soutien
nécessaire le 36 mhz
c'est que 30 ne dit pas des choses que
les gens ne croient pas ils n'essayent
pas de vous induire en erreur
il dit des choses très simples que
depuis longtemps les américains espèrent
que des hommes politiques auront le
courage de dire donald trump le dit
donald trump le fait les américains
n'oublieront pas le mouvement restera
fort restera puissant car le peuple
attendra toujours certaines choses que
son gouvernement et si le gouvernement
nous rejette ça ne tiendrait ses
promesses
alors
il y aura des dégâts nos politiques je
pense que demain trains restera très
puissante pour beaucoup d'années merci à
vous des parkings animateur radio
analystes politiques partisans donc on
l'a bien compris de donald 30
toujours aux états unis sur le front
sanitaires se sont un peu plus de deux
millions de personnes qui ont reçu
l'injection anticopie de 19 depuis le 12
décembre une vaste opération qui
n'avance pas assez vite pour joe biden
le président élu des pleurs des retards
dans la distribution des vaccins il
appelle l'administration trump à tenir
ses engagements
locataire de la maison blanche avait
promis à la vaccination de 20 millions
de personnes
avant la fin de l'année on voit cela
avec grégoire d'aussi près de 20
millions de cas détectés pas loin de
trois cent quarante mille morts
enregistrés depuis le début de la
pandémie
ce triste bilan fait des états unis le
pays le plus durement touché par le cos
vite 19 dans le monde
avec les nombreux déplacements liés à
thanksgiving et aux fêtes de fin d'année
les chiffres n'ont fait que s'aggraver
et pour ne rien arranger un premier cas
du variant britannique du virus
nettement plus contagieux a été détectée
ce mardi dans l'état du colorado
le gouverneur police et les responsables
sanitaires de l'état ont annoncé avoir
détecté un premier cas au colorado du
variant b1 1,7 du coc vie 19 le même
variant découvert au royaume uni
l'individu est un homme d'une vingtaine
d'années qui est actuellement à l'
isolement dans le comté d'el berthe et
n'a pas d'antécédents de voyage des
nouvelles très inquiétante d'autant que
l'objectif affiché par donald trump de
vacciner 20 millions d'américains d'ici
la fin de l'année ne sera pas atteint
une situation dénoncée par joe biden y
regrette ce retard pris dans le plan de
vaccination
l'effort de distribution et
d'administration du vaccin ne serait ce
pas comme il le devrait
qu'il ya quelques semaines
l'administration trump a suggéré que
millions d'américains pourraient être
vaccinées d'ici la fin décembre
reste que quelques jours en décembre il
nous n'en avons vacciné que quelques
millions jusqu'à présent
et si le programme de vaccination
continue d'avancer à ce rythme là il
faudra des années et non des mois pour
vacciner tous les américains
en attendant de déballer ses cartons la
maison blanche l'administration de biden
encourage plus que jamais les américains
à se faire vacciner pour enrayer une
épidémie hors de contrôle
ce mardi la vice présidente élue kamala
harris s'est à son tour fait inoculé le
remède
je viens d'être vaccinés comme dur le
dis souvent il ya une grande différence
entre le vaccin et les vaccinations
je veux encourager tout le monde à se
faire vacciner c'est relativement
indolore cela va très vite c'est sans
danger
joe biden a d'ores et déjà prévenu s'il
espère des progrès à l'horizon du mois
de mars
les prochaines semaines seront
certainement les plus difficiles depuis
le début de la pandémie effet la fin de
cette émission vous retrouverez
stéphanie de méreau commandes de
l'émission dès lundi prochain
on se retrouve dans quelques minutes
pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité à tout
[Musique]
quelle image il laisse de lui diego
maradona en argentine il est su